madonna
anyway she would not approve of any of
this goofiness i feel like she's so damn
cool
let's serve up some news sunny side up
next up american icon william shatner is
about to boldly go where no 90 year old
man has gone before
i don't think that has anything to do
with star trek that's just my weird
like line reading no wonder i didn't get
those jobs
people reports tomorrow captain kirk is
actually going into space
for reals shatner will be launched into
the stratosphere on jeff bezos's blue
origin rocket that looks so much like
something else
come on
does nobody think that looking at this
am i the only one
does it have to be that shape no
now that you mention it hi
sorry
suddenly i want to go into space
nme reports madonna's new live concert
film madame x
is out on paramount plus right now
cameras followed her on tour dates for
75 days around the world and i was lucky
enough to be in the audience for the new
york premiere
uh-huh and i got to ask her a question
madonna
by the way she would not approve of any
of this goofiness i feel like she's so
damn cool
um but i wanted to share the moment with
you so take a look
my question for you was have you said no
to anything
that you wish you had said yes to and
what was that thing oh that's not good
good question yeah i was given a script
to the matrix i was offered the role of
trinity yeah and
i'm kidding i read this script i'm like
this is the stupidest i've ever read
what i turned it down
[Laughter]
chelsea put out these debates on
instagram and online it was do you do
your toilet paper under or over
uh-huh um raise of hands who's in over
yeah raise your hands if you're an under
okay we are animals apparently
and then show this towel picture because
i participated in this too and like the
biggest movie stars on the planet
participated in this uh raise your hand
if you're a one
raise your hand if you're a two
okay that's then three
oh you okay three looks like you're
living in a spa
right congrats on your life if you're a
three literally what is wrong with me i
am an under and a and a sad folder what
what's wrong with me these are such this
is i didn't know that i was i know i
don't think a lot of people knew until
it was put in front of them and then
people went nuts about it so yeah it is
a very it's a it's very divisive yes it
is i mean you had like the biggest stars
in hollywood chiming in about how
they're an over or an under or a towel
folder anyway when it's over i feel like
it just never ends and you waste toilet
paper
mpr recently spoke to the author of a
new book who claims laziness is a lie
devin price is a social psychologist and
in their book
laziness does not exist they say that we
should reframe laziness and see it as a
sign from our bodies that it is time to
take a rest see it as a sign and not a
flaw
what do you guys think of that
i mean
we're so
hard on ourselves and we think that rest
isn't productive we think it is lazy and
we don't realize that it's like the most
productive thing we can do we can fill
our cups so we can pour
into our jobs pour into our family and
we just we push it aside and say oh it's
not important or we're so hard on
ourselves yeah we are hot on ourselves
and sometimes if you've done this where
you've said something to yourself that
and talk to yourself like you would
never speak to another person
why are we so hard on ourselves like
talk to yourself like you talk to your
best friend
best life reports that the dating app
plenty of fish found one-third of daters
say that they delete all photos of their
ex off instagram after a breakup it's
called sanitizing and for many people
it's very cathartic just ask j-lo cause
she recently scrubbed her instagram of
every last trace of a-rod did she really
she totally derotted her
yes
yes
yes and i would like to know ross is
your instagram free x-free
uh no no it's not xv this is gonna be a
complicated conversation because
i believe you know your exes are part of
you you know whether you like it or not
they become part of the fabric of who
you are like a tattoo or nacho bell
grande they just become
part of you and i don't think you should
sanitize your instagram i'm in the
relationship i'm in now engaged bt dubs
thanks so much
but i am a fully formed man who knows a
thing or two about life because of my
past relationships i'm so grateful for
them i completely agree
it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
of things that i love that i think you
might want to know about but today we're
here with audrina biges
from cbs2 chicago's morning news she's
been with us throughout the entire show
and audrina
you're gonna put a pic into the little
yellow book today yes we are coming from
chicago it's the perfect fall treat
we're in that mode straight from the
windy city so this is pumpkin spice
coffee from chicago french press what i
love about this
is that it's female owned it's black
owned they make this in small batches
it's with medium roast coffee beans from
el salvador the pumpkin spice that
you're gonna taste is made in-house and
the coffee has notes of nutmeg and
cloves all those things that make us
feel so good inside and i wanted to
taste it together all right ready one
two three here we go don't burn your
mouth i know i hope i don't
let me tell you something you know what
i love about this it's not too pumpkiny
no right it doesn't go
in your face it's not a word but you
understand what i'm saying right this is
the beginning of a beautiful friendship
yes i love it
[Music]
you